Hello.
Right. Oh [\h__\h] Hello. Um, right. I'm a
little bit slow today. Well, past couple
of days I'm jetlacked out of my mind.
So, I apologize if I make even less
sense than usual. Um, my name is Georgie
and I hack things for a company based
out of the UK called Interup Labs. And
today I'm going to talk about my journey
into AI and how I ended up using AI for
um what essentially was a successful
entry at the last mobile pontoron
edition. Um, is it safe to assume
everyone's heard of ponton? Um, if
you've if you have no idea what
pontonone is, can you please raise your
hand? Okay. So pon is a contest happens
uh once nowadays twice or whatever a
year where a company called trend AI
well zdi the zero day initiative uh will
bring out some real world targets like
phones routters printers naz whatever
and they invite people to demonstrate
and exploit uh using durase
um so that's essentially what pontoon is
Um, I've been doing puntor for maybe
over 10 years now, and I've mostly been
focused on Android targets over the
years, and I'm getting really bored. Um,
nothing's really changed for a couple of
the vendors I've been targeting over the
years. Uh, it's essentially the same
bugs over and over again. Um,
the only issue is it's getting a bit
more difficult to find these bugs
because they're buried in a huge amount
of applications and some of the bug
bounties out there are wiping the
lowhanging more obvious bugs. Um, so I
decided, okay, well, that's a great
excuse to teach myself um AI. um Android
applications the delvic executable file
format decompiles nicely to human
readable Java. So, you know, human
readable Javas potentially a great um
input for LLM and so many of these bugs
that I'm talking about, they're very
obvious patterns that might not
necessarily be the easiest one for a
static analyzer to pick up, but when you
see one, you know instantly there's
something wrong going on. So this kind
of pattern matching is probably another
great um problem for for an LLM to work
on obviously. And last but not not least
um there's absolutely no privacy
concerns in my day-to-day job as a von
researcher. Um unfortunately we've not
really found a way to use um LLMs uh at
the minute. Uh but um ponton was was was
great excuse because we obviously don't
care about these bugs. These bugs will
eventually end up with the ponton
organizers. Right. So before I actually
dig into the agendic solution which is
the focus of this talk, I obviously
decided to um well make sure there's
actually something out there. Um I
actually was a bit of a skeptic. but
didn't really know if I should uh buy
into this hype. Um so I'm like okay well
let's copy paste some output from a tool
like Jeb or Jadex basically a tool that
will decompile an Android application to
Java and like paste some of this input
into a a chatbot and see what comes back
and you know surprisingly like some of
these bugs instantly picked up like okay
well there's something there. Um,
unfortunately there wasn't really a
decent uh plug-in for Jeb or Jaddex to
use to like use a chatbot as an
assistant. So I kind of focused a little
bit for a short period of time on
Android Studio because it's what
supposedly what real developers use. So
hopefully better support for some of
these assistants out there. So you can
use Jadex to decompile the app and then
export as a gradal project and then
import it into Android Studio and then
take advantage of some of these like Jet
Brains AI assistant or C- pilot plugins
or whatever to ask questions about the
app, ask the ask the model to clean up
the app, tidy up the some of the
partially obiscated source, etc. Well,
long story short, I wasn't so happy with
the with the integration, but I was um
surprised by the by the outputs um like
using
again chat style bots ad hoc. Um I was
like okay well let's see what the
agentic stuff is all about. And there
isn't actually I'm talking about August
last year so maybe there's something
nowadays but August last year I'm like
is there something I can use agentbased
that will just consume an Android
application go and find bugs in it well
couldn't find anything at the time so
I'm like right I mean that's another
good excuse to like try and learn
something new for once
um and this is what the really high
level design of the um solution looks
like. So I use lang chain for the agent
or the set of agents uh that I have
nowadays. I've got Jadex again the
application used to decompile uh Android
applications to Java. Uh the agent
speaks to light LLM just to help with
the management for some of these models.
All of these models run on Azure Foundry
and I've got Langfuse for um
introspection and observability.
So again, I have no idea what AI is at
this point or how I'm supposed to
actually be using this. So I'm extremely
naive and I decide to go with a two
agent setup. One agent to identify
what's the valid attack surface in the
target application. Then produce some
list of entry points into the
application and then hand this list over
to a bug hunter um agent.
And the bug hunter agent is supposed to
like go and find bugs for me. And this
whole setup speaks to JREX via these
JREX MCP. Couple of words on the Jax
MCP. The it was heavily based on an
open- source implementation
by this uh guy. It's it it wasn't ideal,
but it was pretty much the only
available option at the time. Um, so
it's uh the JADAX it's implemented as a
JADX plug-in that essentially runs uh an
HTTP server embedded into into the
plug-in and exposes some JADX internal
API that you can interact with from the
outside and the actual MCP part is just
a Python like fast MCP implementation
that wraps the rest style endpoints from
the embedded server and you've got tools
like fetch me the Android manifest. This
is a description of what the app does,
all of the components of the app. Um
there's tool to retrieve source code for
a particular method, same one for a
class, tool to actually search through a
list of classes defined in the app,
etc., etc. Like all of the stuff you
would imagine as a reverse engineer you
might want to ask questions about.
some really obvious mistakes early on.
So, I was literally like, "Right, I'm
looking for bugs. This is the app. Go
and find bugs." Well, that's clearly not
how it works. Um, the app like the agent
didn't really know what's going on. It
didn't really know what I'm asking. um
it gets really confused and it gets
easily lost and just runs out of tokens,
runs out of uh coal like tool call
limits, etc., etc. And again, so very
extremely vague objective and very fuzzy
success like criteria like the the the
agent doesn't know what kind of bugs I'm
looking for. Uh it doesn't know exactly
where to look for these bugs. It it it
was just a nightmare. I was like, "Okay,
well, this agenda stuff is kind of BS."
Um, then again, chatting to a few
people, they're like, "Well, you
absolutely misusing this. This is not
how you use AI." I'm like, "Okay,
interesting." Then the first and most
obvious issue was to like tell the agent
like in a more structured manner where
to look for bugs and then iterate over
the entry points defined well discovered
by the attack surface analysis agent. So
instead of just looking for bugs in the
app in general, you say start looking
for bugs in this one particular
component.
um you get way further into the the core
graph and then if you even break this
down further and say well start looking
for bugs in this component
reachable exactly through an intent
filter defining this data format etc. So
you give some extra guidance to keep it
on track for longer. Uh some more
mistakes well the MTP server wasn't
ideal. Um the tool descriptions were a
bit vague and messed up maybe. Um the
code search was extremely slow. The
error messages were extremely unhelpful.
Um basically whenever you encounter a
problem, you just return a message
saying there's been an error. So it's
not really helpful to the agent and like
you're not really guiding the agent how
to use the tool if it fails to use it
properly. So a lot of these are easily
like solvable. um you just implement
some additional tools if necessary to
like expose more granular tools. And I
think what made um a lot of difference
in this case was uh just returning some
actionable error messages. So the agent
can actually um retry based on like
retry wi with with like some sort of
idea what may have gone wrong and like
try and tweak the input for the tool
based on the error message. Um system
prompt improvements. Uh basically like I
had to be extremely I realized at this
point I'm dealing with a with an intern.
Like if I had an intern for the summer
and I want this intern to find bugs on,
I need to be very well it it's literally
like describing the process that I have
deeply ingrained in deep in my brain
that like what I actually look for and
what primitives I'm aware of that that I
need to chain together to have a
successful exploit. So I had to be very
explicit about all of these. Um, I need
to specify some priorities in terms of
the actual bug classes I'm looking for,
etc. And the agent was always, always,
always trying to suggest some fixes and
mitigations. I'm like, shut up. Stop
wasting my tokens. I don't care about
any of this [\h__\h] Okay, so this is
probably the the least interesting part
of the talk. These are the two bugs that
we ended up chaining for pawn to own.
So, the initial agent implementation is
still like extremely basic. There's like
no verification. There's very little
guard rails. Like it it's it's it's
shite, but it still found stuff like it
found a lot of stuff actually.
Surprisingly, it found probably over a
dozen bugs that had to be manually
verified at this point. Um, and again,
we we chained two of these bugs uh
together. So, and and the agent wasn't
able to figure out these two bugs can
actually be used in in some sort of
chain. So the first bug it was in a
application called smart touch call um
which is some sort of interactive
customer service app for Sammy uh
customers
um and it's a like really traditional
obvious
URL validation problem. So you send the
URI to the app essentially and they
extract some parameters out of the URI,
treat one of the parameters as a um as a
URL and then load this URL into a web
view which is just an embedded browser
that runs in the app. Um the interesting
bit about this web view was the fact
that it's got a very custom web chrome
client implementation which is basically
the bit of the web view that dictates
how permissions are managed in in in
this web view. And this particular web
chrome client basically gives you access
to your microphone, camera, geoloccation
and a couple of other bits and bobs.
Normally when you ask for this in a
browser or in any other web view, you
get a notification, you get a prompt and
you need to confirm all of these one by
one based on the origin or whatever. But
this one was just like, okay, go ahead.
Like you've got access to any of these.
Um, this is what the entry point looks
like. You've got the name of the
activity. It's called web view activity.
Nice. Uh, it's got a scheme and a host
which basically tells you how to reach
this application. So when you click on a
link sdc.skin
sldc/
whatever from a from a browser or from a
instant message or whatever the Android
operating system will know exactly how
to routt this message to to the to the
target application to the target
activity. So they retrieve some details
out of the what what's called an intent.
The intent is just a bit of data that
goes from the browser, let's say, to the
application and you can bundle some
intent extras and you can bundle some
URI parameters. So, they extracted a lot
of these and um I mean it's really hard
to tell exactly what they were aiming
for, but um there was some like really
sloppy checks to try and make sure they
load the correct uh URL and they do some
validation on the URL and they make sure
the URL matches what they've tried to
hardcode into the application. It
doesn't matter like probably safe to
disregard all of this. The end result is
you reach this web view.post URL uh sync
uh with a URL that you control fully. So
you get to execute JavaScript in this
web view. And once you execute
JavaScript in this web view, obviously
you get access to all of these like nice
things like a camera, microphone, etc.,
etc., etc. So this is a report from the
bug hunter. Um it's obviously trimmed
down significantly. Uh but it tells you
oh there's uh this like web view that
you can reach. Um you need to like it
actually provides some sort of trigger
for me to actually try and reproduce the
bug and it tells me this is the sync.
This is where you end up executing
JavaScript in this web view etc etc. Um
there was a bit of a problem actually.
Um the agent didn't highlight the custom
web chrome client. So it didn't tell me
I get access to all of these nice bits.
Um, and it also missed an important like
crucial part. Uh, there was a check in
the application. Literally, the first
thing it does is check if you're on a
phone call. Like if there's an ongoing
phone call, proceed and load this into
web view. If you're not on a phone call,
just drop the entire like request or
whatever. So, nothing really happens.
And that's a very strange prerequisite
for your exploit to work. but it's also
what makes it the perfect meme exploit
for for the contest. Um, so second bug
to the rescue, the agent found a bug in
Bixby, which is Samsung's AI assistant,
which is really really nice and funny
and ironic. And again, very like sort of
similar bug. You end up executing
JavaScript in a web view in in the Bixby
application. And once you're in that
Bixby application, you can speak to
components from the Bixby application
that are not exposed to to um other
applications on the phone directly. Um
this is what it looks like again. Um
they take some data, they extract some
bits and bobs of the URI and then they
try to validate the the URI. And
basically, long story short, any
subdomain of mcsvc.samsung.com
samsung.com can be loaded into this web
view. Well, the issue is there's like
plenty and plenty of subdomains and sub
subdomains of this domain and some of
them have cross-sight scripting. So, you
just um run your JavaScript in them uh
well um in this origin and you execute
JavaScript in that web view. This is
what the bug report looks like for like
it's captured two bugs in in in this
scenario. So it says, "Oh, the host
validation's really relaxed that they're
loading essentially any subdomain or sub
subdomain or whatever for this very
broad Samsung domain. So you might want
to look out for this one and see if
there's any interesting like uh
JavaScript executing already on this
domains that you can leverage for a
cross-ite scripting or whatever." And
then it tells me, oh yeah, by the way,
there's like a very privileged uh
JavaScript interface that you can reach
from once you're executing in this uh
web view. Um this is the demo from the
contest. So basically you have the phone
target phone on the left and you click a
link. This is this is what happens at
Pontton. Like you click one link and
that's it. Like what happens is you go
to this uh Bixby web view. Um once
you're in the Bixby web view, you ask
Bixby to make a phone call to whatever
number. Once you make a phone call,
you're able to bypass the phone call
check in the other application. So you
end up in the other application and you
get access to the camera feed, etc.,
etc.
Okay. um a bit on the agent evolution.
Uh implemented an APK harvesting tool.
Uh basically just some scripts uh put
together to retrieve APKs from app
stores to like start scanning for bugs
at scale. Uh decouple the Android
manifest analysis logic. Well, the
attack surface analysis logic. There's a
like a standalone script because I
realized there's no point uh using an
LLM for something that's extremely
deterministic. I know exactly what I'm
looking for. Um, and further refined the
the bug hunting scope. So,
previously I would ask the app to start
looking for bugs reachable via this
intent filter. This is like entry point
number one. Then you've got another
intent filter. This is entry point
number two. Then I realized there's
intent filters with like very obvious
paths u like sub entry points into the
intent filter essentially. So you can
reach multiple features via any of these
uh which makes sense to like start
treating this as um as unique entry
points into the app. Um I also realized
some of the apps um comes as no surprise
are slightly offiscated and the agent
like works a lot better on a on a like a
cold like base that's been slightly the
offiscated. I noticed this when I was
manually doing it and I'm like well I
can just hook the uh buck hunter uh
agent and whenever it makes a request
for source code it will go via the code
the offiscator and the code the
offiscator will speak to the jadex mcp
and like fetch the source clean it up a
bit and then return the the source back
to the buck hunter and this this was
this made quite a quite a difference
like you can see uh one two three letter
method names and class names uh get very
meaningful names that really help the
agent gauge exactly what's going on. Um
some more improvements um I realized I
run the agent once I get a set of
results I run the agent a second time on
the second on the same entry point and I
get a different set of results and
obviously this makes sense to everyone
who's worked with AI. So I'm like okay
well just start running it like between
one and five times depending on how
interested I am in this uh entry point
and start aggregating bugs uh bug
reports and then run the bug reports
through a dduplicator agent that
basically takes a list of bug reports
and tries to extract the the unique bug
reports the bug reports capturing unique
bugs. Um added another agent to like
start converting bug reports to JSON.
Uh, I don't know if that's a thing, but
I noticed whenever I try and enforce a
strict schema on the output, the the
output will sometimes like degrade in
quality. So, I had to like like do it as
as a like a secondary like
post-processing step. Um, and I also
realized I've got many agents at this
point and they all share bits and bobs
of the system prompts. So I started
managing the system prompts using Ginger
uh Ginger 2 to like pick like different
snippets of system prompts and use them
across the the set of agents. Uh finally
introduced the bug verifying agent. So
whenever I find something with the bug
hunter, I pass it on to the verifying
agent.
uh made life so much easier and needless
to say and I also added a source to sync
reachability tool based on suits up uh
which is a framework for uh processing
Java byte code and creating core graphs
out of this bite code. So you can then
start looking for paths from one part of
the b uh of the core graph to another
part. Um, this is just a snippet from
the bug verifier run on the one of the
the bugs that was reported by the bug
hunter and it basically tells me this is
not a valid bug actually because you
won't be able to reach this based on the
circumstances you described in the
system prompt because this is only
reachable when you're on an active call.
If you're not on a call, you won't be
able to see this.
Um, it's a double-edged sword because if
the agent decided this is not reachable,
I would have never seen it probably.
Anyway, so this is the current design.
We've got a set of scripts doing all the
deterministic bits and bobs. And we've
got a bug hunter looking for bugs. We've
got uh bug duplicator the duplicating
the the bugs. We've got the code the
offiscator cleaning up the code. We've
got another agent to like reformat the
the reports to JSON. And we've got a bug
verifier. And then we've got obviously
on the MCP side Jax and Suitup
um road map uh maybe some sort of static
analysis integration um start running
static analyzers and let the agent
triage the bugs coming out of the static
analyzer.
uh maybe some sort of way to start
tracking bugs across different apps
because at the minute the agent can can
only see bugs within one app and like
there's no like very often you need to
start chaining things together across
multiple apps in order to get a useful
primitive out of them and a useful
exploit. So maybe some sort of database
where the agent can see all of the bugs
we've got at the minute. Um, and last
but not least, and actually something
we've been working on, uh, introduce
some pog generation and runtime proof of
vulnerability. So you plug your phone
into your laptop, you run ADBMCP, you
run Freda MCP, and you let the agent
test the trigger produced by the bug
report uh by the bug hunter and then
refine the pock while collecting some
events using Freda hooks and ADB lockat
um events.
And that is it. Thank you. Thank you.
questions for Georgie?
>> All right, we want to go.
>> Thank you. Thanks.